welcome to the billionaire mindset your
30-day journey to
thinking like a billionaire now you can
just watch this video or if you want to
sign up for the entire series for free
and get the bonus pdf
companion calendar check the link in the
description below today is day four and
we're going to learn the wake up habits
of billionaires
enjoy
[Music]
what is my belief practice today
today
i feel the fierce
love of all that is god
so deeply
so strongly and so purely in my heart
that it lifts
and carries me and
sometimes i actually feel weightless in
the love that is god
because i feel it in all things
i actually awakened to birds twittering
in the morning now
the original tweets and
because i'm not so focused
on because i've reached a point in my
life
where i actually pay attention
to every breath and my spiritual
practice
is that i awaken and the first thought
is thank you
and the next thought is i'm still here
in this body and
my heart's desire is to want to live and
be in this body
fully present to everything
to all beings to all things
to not miss this experience of being
here
now on the planet we call earth
i get up in the morning and i learned
this years ago
and i you go to the bath machine
normally do you go back
i have to go in the middle of the night
so then in the morning right yeah yeah
i'm like i think i woke up at three it's
only 6 30.
you just sit there and you clear your
mind that's not easy our minds go fast
so
i look at the wall i look at the ceiling
okay it's the ceiling
that's the lamp uh that's the bottom of
the bed uh there there's my dog susie
outside ready to jump in the colorado
river it was i just i focus
right then i go right back and maybe
i'll look at a wall and i'll just
clear my head anything enters my head
i'll look at the doorway i'll look at
anything to go into present time
it only takes to come and just be
sometimes i close my eyes sometimes
they're open
i just be and then almost every single
day what comes out of me
either quietly or verbally loudly is
creator of souls thank you for this
incredible life you have given me
and help me see the truth and now i can
spread goodness with this blessing you
have given me
and then my mind is usually pretty clear
and then i go about my day i don't think
about things what i'm going to do during
the day
nothing until that happens and i'm
probably good for that 95 percent of the
time you know it's just
like what age did you start doing that
whatever it is it just clears it
you've done that how long oh god i'd say
for
i could even tell you at least a decade
maybe longer wow
just clears your head instead of
meditating there forever it's like
exercising
there are many exercises you could do
some it's an hour's worth of exercising
two hours three hours and all of a
sudden comes along an exercise
that takes 10 seconds but exercises
everything in your body
that was a shortcut but to accomplish
the same thing
so not that what i'm telling you and
your audience
surpasses meditating for hours i'm sure
that's probably great
i just didn't choose to do that and try
and find a shorter time
to do something would normally take a
longer time to achieve something good
now i'm going through and teaching
myself neural networks and you know
doing the same thing with machine
learning and gans and this and that
because ai is going to have more of an
impact
than the internet did ai plus new types
of chipsets
plus 5g is going to change things far
more than we've ever seen
anything change and understanding where
and how to apply it
is going to be critical but just as
important knowing how to sep
segregate and separate the [ __ ]
right is as important because
every email you are about to send me is
going to say
i have this ai solution and we're using
algorithms
yeah of course you are right and then
what what really makes you different
what really sets you apart but if i
didn't do that work
if i didn't sit down and do the aws
machine learning tutorials if i didn't
go on youtube and take
you know the nyu introduction to neural
networks or whatever
i'm not going to know it i'm not going
to be able to apply it and i'm not going
to be able to be first
and that's fun that's fun knowing i get
to kick the ass to some 22 year old nyu
graduate that's awesome you know the
first question you're going to get asked
when you go to
apply for a job whether it's now or some
point in the future
is what did you learn what did you do
what skills did you add during the
pandemic of 2020
and i think it's imperative to anybody
looking to
to get a job to really push themselves
forward
to do better than their parents to
really place a focus on learning
you know i i think you'd agree mike and
anybody watching that one of the
greatest skills that we all can have
in the in the business world is a thirst
for knowledge just being excited about
learning
and knowing how to learn and this really
is the best opportunity
ever for people to add to their skills
whether it's taking a coursera
class or you know in the past i would
have said reading a lot of books but now
having learned from my kids
going on youtube and you know watching
tutorials and watching videos on various
subjects you know i learned how to write
a three-letter three-layer javascript
neural network on youtube
and so there's a unique opportunity now
for you to add skills
particularly in areas like artificial
intelligence that are going to be in
great demand that most people have not
yet learned because
you know it's it's so recent that it's
become really applicable
the same thing i told myself the same
thing i tell everybody one
you're 21 22 23 years old right
you don't have to figure it out right
now don't try
right you spend all this money sorry
um pain to learn
now it's your chance to get paid to
learn you don't need the perfect job
you just need to go somewhere where
you'll learn and start
to be exposed to different ideas and now
it's not like you know
when when greg 40 years ago was
graduating
and me five years ago you know it was
like get a career
and you know the pressure was get a
career go work for
ibm or general motors and get a pension
those days are gone
people can't even pay their pensions
anymore and so
you're a free agent and you're always
going to be a free agent on the market
you guys are the kevin durants and
lebron james you know where you're
always out there
and can go find a better situation for
yourself
do what's best for you what have you got
to lose like when i started my company
you know after i got fired by michael
umeki
um
you know what was how bad could it be i
would lose my motel six
towel you know it was just like what
have you got to lose and yeah i
understand there's pressures from
student loans and there's a lot of
conversations we can have there
right but you know you can get a job
that doesn't have to be perfect
you can learn at that job and you guys
have the pedigree you have the brains
you have the initiative to go out and
try the next job
you know you know the good news is the
economy is good enough that it may not
be perfect but you can go job to job
don't look for the perfect answer just
look to get the experience look to learn
because all these different exposures
all the different things you learn
learning how to learn
that's what's going to give you get you
excited and juice you for for something
that you love
because once you find something you love
to do
that's when the magic happens because
when you're when you're
able to find something you love to do
then you can start work focusing on how
can i be great at this
and like greg found out he was a great
networker i like to you know
play with technology and try to do
things first you know whatever it is
that you find about yourself
then you can try to be great at it and
it's rare when people quit
things they're great at you know and so
trying those things
so that that's how i advise people don't
don't stress just go out and try
different things
i like to read more than most kids i
really like to read a lot
my aunt edie gave me a copy of the world
almanac
and that was heaven to me and i can
still tell you that almost population
was 214
0006 in 1930. some numbers just kind of
stick with you
and very early probably when i was seven
or so i took this book out of the
benson library called a thousand ways to
make a thousand dollars
and one of the ways in this book was
having
penny weighing machines
[Music]
and i sat and calculated how much it
would cost to buy the first weighing
machine
and how long it would take for the
profit for that one to buy another one
i would sit there and create these
compound interest tables
to figure out how long it would take me
to have a weighing machine for every
person in the world
first books i read on investment were
actually in my dad's office
pretty soon i read all the books in the
office and read some of them more than
once
a few years ago i went to amazon and
sure enough they had this manual there
so
while reliving my youth other guys were
going to amazon probably and
and buying old playboys or something but
i bought old
movies manuals instead and when i got
out of school
i started selling stocks i was 20 years
old at the time and
looked about 16 and acted about 12 so i
was not the most impressive sales person
anybody ever met but what i would do was
i
i went through page by page looking for
possibly undervalued stocks i wake up
you know really early every day uh and i
play tennis with somebody who's
um a lot younger and a lot fitter than
me and we play singles
and you know we give it every everything
we can
and you know end up uh you know and and
and
end up um you know sweating big time and
and having a lot of fun
at this you know as well and then if the
wind is up you know go for a kite surf
um uh you know kiting's um
you know a lovely way just to get get
away from you know the mobile phones and
and and just get you know get out on the
sea
um and um uh
and then you know after that you know
come back have a
you know have a sort of nice healthy
breakfast generally
sometimes uh you know sometimes they are
not so healthy i found your kryptonite
and um uh and um you know and then and
then i'm ready
you know then i'm ready for the day i'm
inspired by you know
life and all sorts of things you can say
something right now and what inspired me
to write a song or
something to happen you know most kings
just happened to be inspired by basquiat
drawing you know the drawn and he had
most young kings get their head cut off
on the bottom and i looked at that and i
was like
it's powerful you know just the
statement in itself
you know lends itself for a song song
starts inspired by basquiat
my chariots on fire everybody took shots
hit my body up i'm tired
and then it's just they build me up to
break me down to build me up again
they're like oh we need you back so we
could kill you ass again you know it's
like this
thing that's love hate the thing that
the world has
with success period you guys are just
getting started
you're not going to start right here
you're going to start down there
okay probably in another city another
town i grew up in lake charles louisiana
no money
raised by a single mother i was in debt
at 25 years old
the first thing that i had to do in my
life was not
learn a new skill first thing i had to
do
to get my life moving in the right
direction was self-development
it is vital it was vital for me that i
improved myself and i could start
depending upon me
i had to show up every day with some
rituals some disciplines
and start getting myself to trust me not
trust others but trust myself
to do the right thing every day one of
the things that i started doing was
beating the sun up every morning
i'm going to beat that sun up every
morning so that i had the discipline and
the control
over my life so i knew hey
before that thing pops i'm gonna pop i'm
gonna get out of bed depend on myself
get up at the same time every day and
for me that time regardless of where i
was
was beat that sun up no matter where i
am i'm gonna beat that thing up
so it gives me a sense of control over
my own life second thing
i had to start cleaning up my life and
my friends and my environment
when i was younger between 15 and 25 i
was doing crazy stuff in my life
wasting my weekends i have the same
weekends are for the week
i was drinking fooling around with a
bunch of
bad things bad people making poor
choices
at 25 years old i cleaned it all up quit
going to those places
quit using those things quit hanging out
with people that did not have
ethics and discipline in their life that
weren't committed to the same things
that i was
i wanted to build something in my life i
wanted to become someone
and to do that to become someone in the
eyes of the world
the first thing i had to do was become
someone i could depend on
so put some things together three or
four things you can do every day to
start the day
kick-start your day get going in your
day
to give you a sense of respect for
yourself
accomplishment for yourself look just
beating that sun up every morning
gives me the sense of accomplishment
that i did what i said
said i was gonna do that i woke up when
i said i would wake up
and i start building respect for myself
start believing in myself
so that i can go out into the world and
maybe maybe
maybe today maybe today when i go into
this meeting
that i'm dressed for maybe they'll
believe in me as much as i believe in me
and that'll show up in a contract a deal
maybe even some money
people got to keep working on themselves
yeah trying new things
you got to give something up like i'm
always giving stuff up
my life changed when i gave stuff up
when i was 25 and i gave drugs up i'm
like okay i'm done
and and then you give up your friends
right
when you start changing they're gonna go
people don't like it they're going to go
or you're going to come back
and if you're not i truly believe that
if you're not changing your friends
you're not changing
your friends should be they should be
like every few years a cycle
yeah or they should be changing growing
with you they're not going to grow with
you really
well i hope they'll grow later i hope
i'm friends with you in 10 years yeah
but but
we will be yeah we will be you know but
but like i know i know
i dated this girl her friends were her
childhood friends
[Music]
she never changed yeah it's tough none
of them changed
the whole group never changed like for
me to change you can't i can't think of
me and your best friends that me and you
are going to have
we're going to change at the same time
we have different reasons to change
throughout life right right
and and elena and i we'll we'll have
different times when we want to change
my kids like
my kids are going to change and they're
going to leave
hundred percent they're gonna leave
right i don't want i don't want to do
this anymore
right and they're gonna go flying
private back to flying commercial
yeah until they coach yeah until they
figure out how to fly
private if if they even want to do that
yeah but but i've always
said i've changed so many times i've
moved i've been five or six different
cities that's been great for me every
every move has been better for me
i've changed friends i've had lifelong
friends that
i know them but you're not hanging out
every day no i moved on
training if you're not going to train
then put a sign on your desk i quit
learning a long time ago and see how
many people want to buy from you
tell your family go home and tell your
wife and your kids i quit learning
i quit reading i quit studying i quit
training i can't get any better
put on there done i'm finished i'm in
retirement early i'm going to purgatory
i'm going to wait it out cross my
fingers
and hope they bring me to sales heaven
look you're done if you don't train
okay now i know you know this you've
heard it i hate to tell you this
my boy mcgregor connor conor mcgregor or
mcgregor
my boy conor mcgregor okay i went and
saw him fight in new york i went and saw
him fight
for one reason because i saw him say i'm
not the best this isn't about talent
it's cause i'm obsessed i out train
everyone else i have to win
so bad i train look if you're not
training that says something about your
obsession or
lack of obsession with winning i want
you to win
i know your your wife or your husband
your spouse your family members your
kids
your mom and dad want you to win at the
next level no matter what they
tell you even if they tell you you're
doing great pat you in the back you know
the truth
you know the truth the only way to win
is to train the only way to win is to
read the only way to win
is to learn learn more listen more learn
something new look we're in a we're in a
time like we've never been before
technologies come and go faster than
people do
things are changing like this whether
it's video you're using or social media
or snap or
or short videos or videos that disappear
or videos that stay
or text messaging that you can create to
push and market and brand yourself
called text messaging which i've been
using a lot look the world's changing
and if you're saying to yourself i'm too
old to learn that well then guess what
you're too old to learn that
if you can't learn anything new just put
i'm ripe
and i'm about to fall off the tree and
nobody's gonna want me
look man you gotta train every single
day like your life depends on it
train every single day i am here today
i own these four companies that i own
the studio my reputation
everything is because when i was 25
years old to the to when i was 30 years
old
every single day i trained watching
video
every day i'd watch the video i'd walk
in and then i would role play and then
we would do a sales meeting
every single day just this depression
thing yeah like this
this is a topic that interests me so
much have you ever dealt with it at all
totally okay almost my whole life still
a little bit
uh no well what happens is socially we
say it's depression
but what if okay what if
it wasn't depression and it was just
truth
that i'm having to sleep with my own
truth that i can do more
right so why wouldn't i be a bit
depressed
if i have this potential and i'm
operating here
every individual knows what they're
capable of right so
if i know i have this much potential
and i'm living here wouldn't i be
like a little bit disappointed with
myself
now where did where what happened where
because back in the 50s
there was no depression nobody was
talking about depression people were
talking about how do i get to the next
level
right today in our in our psychiatric
community where where drugs are
where the average american has eight
prescriptions
sitting in their medicine cabinet
like i'm on one drug i gotta take a
second drug
to handle the third drug because of a
blood pressure drug because of this drug
and dude i'm stacking out like why
because i was depressed why am i
depressed because i don't look like
i don't have his arms i have the
potential to have his arms
maybe not okay pretty close but but but
it would require me to go to work
right or or i need to look a different
way or i'm i'm aging or
whatever the deal is right like so for
me i have always struggled with
depression
but it was more because people were
telling me i was depressed when the
truth is i was just disappointed man
me too i was disappointed with me me too
you know my mom
my mom would always tell me my mom was
always the first person i would call
any time i scored and she was my best
friend
and and she passed when when about nine
years ago when sabrina was born five
days later sabrina was born
and um every score i had i was 51 years
old man
between 25 and 51 every score i had my
mom was the first person i called
mom i did this every time she had the
same response
son that's great but i love you just the
way you are
over and over she told me that and then
one day i'm like
but i don't now i can't really say that
a whole bunch of people are to say why
don't you love you
just the way you are something wrong
with you because there's that whole
culture out there
this this uh i don't know what the term
is but it's a um
this this this holistic idea that you
should love yourself the way you are
i would tell everybody dude if you know
that you can do more
do not love who you are achieve who you
can be
because you can be more he's done it
i've done it and and i did it by by
by replacing the depression concept not
doing the drugs by the way i was put on
them like five or six times
and threw them away and just said you
know what i'm going to go for my goals
i'm going to go for the think my
potential if i'm going to screw this up
i'm a i'm going to screw it up grant's
way
not that way and unfortunately because
we have so much attention on our
physical capacity and limitations
five eight you know i've been a little
guy my whole life
got to feed myself three times a day
because i'm hungry i gotta urinate
you know sometimes with my buddy um i
gotta i got i gotta sleep
nine hours a day eight to nine hours a
day i'm reminded i'm a body
which has been a deception for me
because that's not what i'm
i'm not limited to just that and so it's
been a big trick
thinking oh i just got to take care of
this i got to clothe it
i got to protect it i got to worry about
it the older you get the more you worry
about it
kids can do almost anything you know
kids can jump off a
freaking they can jump out of a car roll
around on the damn grass and
pop up and say yeah that was fun let's
do that again you do that to me man i'm
like
dang that hurt right so you can see a
kid flying down a mountain at 70 miles
an hour man i'm i'm terrified
because i'm gonna break something so
it's that it's that concern about me as
a
like is something going to happen to me
if i wouldn't have been concerned about
myself
my god i could have done anything man i
would have already done it so so that's
how
i would just that's been a big
limitation with what i was talking about
the
the capacity of the individual is
i don't think i've even like remotely
scratched
hopefully if i come back if i can come
back if anybody believes in that kind of
stuff like
then i can come back with oh my god man
maybe i'm not just
five eight 170 pounds you know
little little tiny little tiny ones got
some good guns right now okay
but maybe i can do more than just the
physical limitations that that
that i impose on myself explain how you
went from a salesman who was in it and
hated it
yeah to then you know you moved on and
became self-employed and then you were
speaking about sales and you're like a
sales expert so that's what
20 years in between or 10 years yeah no
there was uh there was maybe uh
25 by the time i'm 26 i'm the top one
percent of
all sales people in the auto industry i
didn't really know what that meant
but but it was important to me that i
was
very good at what i was doing now now
now i was in i i
i went from hating a job in car sales i
remember going out with this girl and
she said
what are you doing i said i'm a car
salesman and she got that look on her
face like oh my god
that's worse than a man yeah you know i
mean
and and and i had this terrible thing
i'm like okay i'm going to get great at
it
i started studying sales every day i
started recording interviews like
literally you'd come in to buy a car
from me and and i i hired my
mom my mom was 70 years old at the time
and i hired my mom and i said you sit
over there and you take notes
really and watch her watch when i lose
her watch what happens then we're going
to
debrief at the end of the deal and i'm
going to see what's working and what's
not i'm recording myself
videoing myself i'm using every little
piece of technology 30 years ago i can
to find out
what am i doing right what am i doing
wrong and what i was doing i didn't know
it then but i was basically codifying
sales
i was learning what does it mean when i
say i'm gonna think about it
when is that real when is it not what
does it mean when it says the price is
too high when's that real when it's not
and i started codifying and writing
taking notes keeping all this
information i didn't know this would
happen but
five years later i'm out on the road
knocking on doors
uh selling a a new way to sell things
you've got this incredible team how like
what do you look for
like like how do you find these
incredible people how do you keep them
motivated
yeah well i don't i don't find them and
and they find me
and and so what we do is we just we get
the beacon the
you know how does facebook attract
talent you know they don't need to go
find them
it's like it's like meat to a shark you
know it's like i'm coming i'm i smell
the blood in the water
so they're going to facebook right how
do you how do you attract great talent
this is what people ask me every day how
do you attract great people dude get so
freaking beaming hot white light that
people are like i want to work on that
project
i went and saw uh hobson shaw last night
i did 333 million it's got rock and stay
the minute
333 million opening weekend worldwide a
third of a billion dollars dude
like ridiculous great movie by the way
had a blast watching it
but you know how does that much money go
to one place
how did that many great people work on
that movie
you know because who's involved in it
right so uh you know greatness attracts
greatness
and and so these people call hey i want
to work for you i had a kid today come
on i want to work for you it's a good
i don't hire about i don't hire people
like i'm not the hire guy
i'm the guy that's creating new
opportunities though that people want to
stay
you know they want to stay in the theme
park
and become their own show so if you
notice i show off my people a lot
i don't like keep them behind the scenes
i'm like here
you know let's have more than the grant
show let's have the grant the frank kern
show the brandon dawson show the jared
show the ryan secco show the real estate
show
let's do a lot of let's show the g e
show elena and myself
let's bring other people and partners in
why do i do that where am i learning
great companies great companies grow
their brands and scale out and do a lot
of different things
one people should be invested in the
beginning and just in themselves
every chance you get to to go to
something that help could possibly help
you
has a if it has a one percent chance of
even
adding to the value you have in your
spend the money don't sit on money money
is useless
so if you have five thousand dollars
left in your account i would spend
the whole 5 000 on yourself when you
spend money on yourself you're going to
start getting better at whatever you're
doing
if you just keep doing it if you keep
spinning it just because you spent it
once and it didn't work go do it again
and then again and then again that that
has been one thing in my life
like if you ask me hey what's one thing
i always invested me first
not the business not the business not
the real estate me
my my condition how am i doing am i
around the right people am i listening
like i don't care what it is dinner
lunch
charities i just go to anything anything
where i think there's
other people doing well like i just want
to hear somebody say something that just
inspires me
so how much you reckon you invest in
yourself every year right now
last year i probably spent you know
a couple hundred grand i've spent more
than that
and i would i'd still spend more than
that so
like it starts with me right how good a
condition i i know people out there
spend more money on their car than they
do themselves
they pay three four five hundred dollars
a month on their car think nothing of it
won't spend 500 on themselves it's
ridiculous it's completely backwards
you're paying the man you're paying for
food you're paying for groceries you're
paying for movies you're paying for
[ __ ] you're paying
you went and bought a house that was the
dumbest thing anybody could do it's the
dumbest thing i ever did was buy a house
i bought a house but and i didn't
improve myself i was improving the hou
i spent more time picking furniture out
than i did hey how do i fix me
how do i get faster more confident
because i bring my confidence or lack of
confidence to every table
nobody ever taught me when i was going
to school 17 years of school
nobody ever said hey maybe you want to
stack up some experiences
and then what happens is kids rather
than going to college what they do
today is they'll go travel for for a
year
dude what you ought to flip it go get
your work ethic in
bank some money make some money i'm
gonna do this left-handed
bank some money and then go on the trip
of your life
oh left-handed i'm so good i'm so
good at everything
you gotta have confidence man so look
look look
the confidence comes from doing stuff
because it comes from doing business
not from traveling right like i know
people that traveled when they were
young and then they go back into the
workplace in the business place and
they're like dude i don't have any
confidence in business
you want to have confidence in business
confidence and money confidence with
your family
confidence that you can go places and
look money might not make you happy i
know some of you believe that but
it gives you the security to go where
you want to do what you want and stay as
long as you want if you can get that
money right
look if you don't have your thing
whatever it is the job the money the
girl
your goals your dreams you gotta leave
where you are you can't win
a mission from home we don't win wars
at home you understand you got to go
someplace
the world's changing how many agree the
world's changing right now
dude the world is changing it's changing
so fast right
you got it you got to take the old ideas
that you have and you got to look at
them again today and say hey
is this true anymore is it true
what am i doing what are me and the wife
doing what business are we building
do i need to work for myself do i really
or do i need to find the right vehicle
that can go far enough long enough
provide enough revenue for the right
people
and get to the top of the food chain you
got to change your friends
if you're friends
you need to make these people your
friends people that have time to get
away
people that are working people that are
creating
surround yourself with people that are
doing things
that that are seeking to be better
i was i was hanging around people that
were destroying themselves every day
people that were criticizing others that
were successful
that were wasting time
beautiful rock they weren't looking for
anything
except how everybody else was wrong how
they had been wronged i know because i
was doing this
i spent all my time talking about how
the rich guy
that was had his kids in tennis classes
and
golf classes uh and they had a boat and
they went skiing
how he was such a prick and when reality
sorry guys didn't mean you to hear that
when in reality she didn't hear that
when in reality i should have been
looking at dude what did this guy do
to create a situation
where he could pay for his kids to learn
tennis if they want to golf
and skiing i was asking the wrong
questions
i would tell my 20 year old self change
the questions you're asking
change the way you look at things
quit being so resentful and hateful
you know quit quit get get your game
together dude you hang around people
that are changing will not change you
i know this whole mastermind thing we
have masterminds i believe they're great
they're awesome but
if ryan back there hangs around me and
i'm changing
that don't mean he's going to change so
look i've seen this for
30 years you know i've gone places where
the the only reason everybody went there
was because they were
working on themselves changing improving
courses classes education
elena and i actually great story about
elena and i
the only reason people went to these
places was to
improve themselves okay i gotta tell you
something
only about ten percent of the people
that went there flew
they were changing they were actually
making the changes
the other people were hanging around
people changing just because you're
around people changing doesn't mean you
are going to change you got to do the
work to change
my brothers and sisters you got to
change
it you know you know ryan hangs around
me if i change my clothes that don't
mean he changes his
if everybody in the house changes their
clothes
takes a shower put some deodorant
it don't mean if ryan does not change
his clothes and take a shower and put on
his deodorant
he gonna stank dropping bombs to change
you gotta change it doesn't matter how
many people you hang around that are
changing
if you hang around everybody just
getting rich getting wealthy doing great
creating stuff and you're not
you're not gonna change to change you
got to change
i don't need to spend time with a mentor
i need to study
a handful of people that have proven
over time
that they were important and that they
did something walt disney he's a mentor
of mine
one guy almost went bankrupt three times
that is a spiritual adventure
like like hey man how do you do that how
do you have a dream how would schultz
with starbucks i don't like his
political
viewpoints but i do like the fact that
no everybody told him starbucks was a
bad idea
he's like yeah okay well whatever it's a
terrible idea steve jobs
total maniac like neurotic
i wouldn't do any of that stuff but i do
i do like the guys ferocious commitment
so if i can take
rob those pieces from different people
right
and say hey man i want to be more like
that guy or that gal
right you know so so you know what i'm
saying like like
that that's my that's my deal like how
can i mix it up with jared how can i
i'm interested in leaving something that
lasts longer than i do
now i've got some special bonus clips
that i think you're gonna enjoy
but before that it's time for the
billionaire mindset
question of the day i wanna know what
was your single biggest takeaway
from this video and your plan of action
for the next week also if you've already
got your billionaire mindset companion
pdf calendar
get ready for another amazing video
tomorrow or if you don't have it yet you
can get it for free in the first line of
the description below and if you're
enjoying this billionaire
mindset series give me a hashtag
billionaire mindset
in the comments below so i can celebrate
you
every day you have to get a little bit
better every day you have to learn a
little bit more
improve a little bit more build a little
bit more self-confidence
self-belief self-love every single day
because if you are only getting
motivated in these little spurts
what's gonna happen is you fall back to
your normal life you fall back to who
you used to be
and you never accomplish the life that
you know you're capable of
i think it's super common with
entrepreneurs we have these moments
where we feel bold we feel unstoppable
we feel powerful
maybe you watch a video like this maybe
you go to an event maybe you hang out
with somebody and you realize
yeah this is what i should be doing this
is what i'm capable of and then what
happens the next day
you wake up and you're back to who you
used to be you're back to
being full of self-doubt back to being
full of self-criticism
back to feeling like it's just not going
to happen
and so then you don't do anything and
and it's
i want you to get off the roller coaster
ride it says constantly up and then back
down and then next week it's up for a
day and then back down
and the way to do it is to focus on
every single day getting a little bit
better
i think it's super important to have a
morning routine uh if you want to put
the entspresso's here this series is
part of your morning routine i'd be
honored to be with you and help coach
you and guide you
for your life but this is why i i make
the videos i make my videos for me
part of my morning routine every day is
i want to watch a video from my channel
i'm a visual learner i like seeing
things instead of just hearing things or
reading things i like seeing it in front
of me
so i make videos i've made thousands of
videos
and every day i watch one because no
matter how great today was
maybe i've learned a lesson from warren
buffett awesome like yeah yeah i gotta
do this i gotta invest in myself
what's gonna happen is tomorrow i'm
going to wake up and and go back to old
evan carmichael
and so i need to be pushed forward again
you're probably the most ambitious
person you know i mean part of the
problem with why you're stuck is
you're around other people who help keep
you stuck you're the one pushing other
people forward you're the one giving
motivation and inspiration
and showing other people what can be
done but who's pushing you
who's the person in your life saying hey
you're capable of more from a loving
place right not
you should be doing this everybody's got
an opinion what you should be doing with
your life
but from a loving push forward to say
you could be doing more
i believe in you you're awesome you
could be michael jordan at something
go do it we just don't have these people
in our lives for the most part right
you're that person for other people
and so i get it through the videos and
you need it every single day
it's like brushing your teeth right you
need if you stop brushing your teeth
you're gonna get cavities
if you brush your teeth once a week
you're gonna get cavities
every day it's gotta be every day you
need it every single day
so put it into your morning routine
whether you love videos
whether you love books whether you love
podcasts whatever
what are you doing you know just don't
feel me jesus
whatever you love doing right whatever
is your way of learning whatever gets
you fired up
motivated inspired that needs to be part
of your daily
daily daily daily
and routine trick for me is find the
source so if you love my videos awesome
there's tons of them that you'll have no
shortage of even karma could be this to
go watch
if you've learned something from
somebody i've profiled if you
love warren buffett then great jump off
of the evan carmichael channel and go
watch
warren buffett videos or go read warren
buffett books
if there's a podcast that you love
listening to and it inspires you great
put that podcast as a part of your daily
routine
there's no one size fits all for
everybody but
just pay attention to the feeling when
you leave
watching a video when you leave reading
the book when you leave listen to a
podcast
do you feel better about yourself do you
feel
pumped up inspired ready to go take
action because all you need is that
little moment
of courage if watching this video gets
you inspired
don't expect that this one video is
going to inspire you for the rest of the
day
right that's not we have too high a
judgment on things right so well i
watched the video and i was pumped up
for
for 30 minutes or an hour and then
things fell back yeah well that's normal
that that's
that's what will happen the difference
is you use that energy to go make
something that's why
at the end of these videos i'm always so
focused on what are you gonna do about
it
you got inspired awesome now what what's
your plan of action what are you gonna
do what's your plan for this week
to use that inspiration that you get and
then
give yourself the courage to go take
some kind of action
that's it don't get upset that the
motivation fades
the inspiration wears off that's okay
that's normal
what are you doing in those 30 minutes
60 minutes two hours
that you feel pumped up for that you
feel things are possible for what action
are you taking
i think it's the most important thing
and so
if you are waking up every day and
feeling like
you're not capable like it's not gonna
happen
and you just have these little moments
of inspiration i need you
badly you need you badly to make part of
your morning routine
the thing that gets you the most fired
up the most bold
the most confident the most passionate
about doing something
put that in your morning routine i'm
just taking a sip
you take it off you can leave you're
just going to an apartment
that's gone we love you nina
whatever makes you feel that boldness
into your morning routine
every single day schedule it in
follow through because if you woke up
and did the thing that made you feel
bold
that made it feel possible that made you
feel like you can do this
right whatever that thing is if you woke
up and you did that thing and you felt
bold for the first 30 to 60 to 120 to
180 minutes of the day if that was you
you're going to create amazing things
if you woke up and you don't do that
consistently you can stay stuck where
you are
so let's make it happen so action item
write down like now while you're feeling
a little bit bold a little bit more
confident a little bit more belief
how are you going to start your day
tomorrow what are you going to do
tomorrow
the first 30 minutes first 60 minutes of
your day what are you going to do what
gets you
the most bold fired up inspired what is
it
write it down and then how can you start
your day with it tomorrow
plan it right now create the playlist
take the book out
right put it on your put it on your
bedside
line up the audio podcast right get the
youtube channel ready to go
so that tomorrow morning when you wake
up and you don't have as much energy as
you do right now
it's just one click away it's right
there in front of you you just have to
press
the play button so that tomorrow you can
have an amazing day
and the next day after and the next day
after and the next day after
because you deserve it because you have
a big message you got a big mission
the world needs what you've got and to
do that you have to invest in yourself
get yourself bold every morning and go
create amazing things when you focus on
progress
instead of the end result that's where i
think
you can keep your motivation and keep
your belief when i first started making
my videos i wasn't getting any results
right nobody was watching nobody was
commenting i felt
like a loser right nobody cares it's not
happening
i'm not getting the results understand
that you very rarely ever get results at
the beginning
if you focus on just getting the results
at the beginning you're likely going to
get too discouraged and quit
it's not that the results aren't
important it's just people have a
too short an attention span and when you
focus on the result at the beginning it
is too discouraging and you do give up
instead you focus on the progress are
you getting better are you learning was
your video
better than last time did you show up
with more energy than last time did you
have
better points than you did last time was
that sales call you did
better than the one last time was your
next test better than it was yesterday
right are you getting better
because if you can say i'm getting
better if you if you're making videos
and you look back
a week later a month later and say man i
still suck but i'm better than i was
a week ago a month ago and you can focus
on the progress
at least for me it really helps fuel my
motivation my belief in myself that hey
if i made that growth from here to here
then i can make more growth from here to
here and at the beginning
here's the thing at the beginning the
growth is pretty fast
when you're learning something from from
scratch at the beginning you actually
learn very quickly
it's at the end that it gets harder for
me
right now to keep getting better is
harder i don't see as big a return
on my on my progress as evan chromical
growth
from last week to this week from last
month to this month how much better am i
on camera
from last month to this month not that
much
it requires even more effort and even
more mentorship and even more practice
and training to get better as
when you're close to the top at the
beginning
you can learn really quickly and there's
a lot of progress the flip side for me
now is
lots of results right when you start
actually getting good that's when the
results kick in
so then you can start focusing on the
results so hey is this working or not is
this video doing better than the last
one or not
because you start getting some data and
results to work with so at the beginning
you're focusing
on the progress am i getting better am i
improving and am i learning is it better
than
than i was last week and then as that
starts to taper off you might get
frustrated with your progress
but good news you're going to start
seeing results come in and that'll keep
you motivated to keep going as well
the fastest path for you to get the
success you're after is to model success
the idea here is simple you find people
who have already done the thing that you
want to do
learn from them understand what they did
to get there and then try on their hat
right see what worked for them and apply
it to your business this is what worked
for me this is what saved my company
bill gates saved my first company even
though i've never met him
i haven't yet we're going to make it
happen hopefully hopefully hopefully
soon
i was struggling i had a upstart
software company that wasn't making
money
and i quit on my business partner and i
woke up the next day and said i need to
find a way to make this happen
like i can't quit on this too soon
because i'm going to regret it if i
don't keep going
and so i said who has done this before
who's done this
and i thought of bill gates which is the
first person that came to mind was bill
gates so i looked at his story and how
did he
build microsoft was through partnerships
and so
i started making partnerships in my
business i had nothing else to lose
there was already at rock bottom right i
heard every quit on my partner
it was hopeless so let's just give this
a shot
and within i don't know a couple months
maybe even sooner
i landed my first partnership deal for
13 and a half thousand dollars and at
the time guys i was making 300 bucks a
month so that money
meant the world to me like that was that
was bank and and more important than
that it
it gave me hope you know like this could
happen this
this business could actually work and it
gave me a model to then go and do it
again and again and again
and ever since then whenever i don't
know what to do i model success i find
someone who's done it
and i try to apply their strategies and
make it work for me
but this is the important thing not
every strategy is going to work the same
way
for them as it did for you so maybe
waking up early is your ticket maybe
waking up later
is gonna be your ticket there's people
who've done both which is the one that's
gonna work for you
you won't know by sitting on the couch
and thinking about it the best thing you
can do
is just go and try you try on their hat
right bill gates did this dan lok does
this bruce lee does this
awesome try it the fastest way to
accomplish anything in life is to model
success
you want business success you want
relationship success you want financial
success
whatever it is you want to learn
somebody's done it and the fastest way
to learn
is to go find somebody understand what
it took for them to become a success
and then apply it to your business to
your life to your situation
the problem is we feel like we have to
do everything ourselves that you don't
know what to do so i'm going to figure
this out right
i'm creative i'm a genius i can i can
figure it out and yes you can but
chances are it's going to take you a lot
longer instead of trying to come up with
everything yourself it's better to build
upon what other people have already done
they could take you eighty percent of
the way it's not going to be a hundred
percent
right if you're trying to get big on
youtube great you can copy what i'm
doing
but it's not going to take you a hundred
percent of the way it'll take you eighty
percent of the way because if all you do
is copy me you're gonna be in evan jr
which will take you a good chunk but
at best you're going to be a junior evan
you're never going to be
what you could be and so you need to
take what i'm doing learn from it but
then
tweak that last 20 to make it your own
how do you take what other people have
done
and then tweak that last 20 to make it
your own but
modeling success takes you 80 other way
this is the biggest mistake i made when
i was starting up as an entrepreneur
right
i told the story a bunch but i was i was
19 i was struggling i was making 300
bucks a month i'm
too embarrassed to tell my friends that
i'm struggling i'm not having success
i feel like a loser i feel like i'm
you know i'm not making any money not
just feel like it i wasn't making any
money
and and i tried to think my way out of
everything i was
working my face off right like every
waking hour almost
i was i was working it wasn't for lack
of effort i was just doing the wrong
thing so they didn't know what to do
because i was just trying a whole bunch
of stuff
and then that worst day of my life when
i told my partner that i quit
you know i just woke up the next day and
said i can't quit because i'm going to
regret this i know i'm going to regret
this advice if i stop now i'm going to
regret it i have to find a way to keep
going but the way that i've kept
the way that i keep going has to change
because what's going on now this
this can't keep going on if you're
frustrated with the lack of momentum
towards accomplishing your goals
in life like if you're in the same spot
that you were a year ago or relatively
close
the problem likely uh could be lack of
effort but it's also like you're just
doing the wrong things you're just
focused on the wrong model
and so go find somebody who's done what
you want to do for me i studied bill
gates
i was out of pure desperation i was not
a genius when i was
19 and uh trying to figure out my way i
was at rock bottom i just said
somebody has built a software company
before
this can't be so hard right and i looked
at bill gates and how he started right
how did he start
zero to one that's what you need to
study because if you look at what people
are doing now
one it it it's gonna be hard to compare
yourself to if you compare yourself to
what i'm doing now i have 20 something
people on my team you can't
like don't expect yourself to keep up
with what i'm doing right now
don't expect to keep up with 11 years of
experience right you're not going to be
as good when you first get started
that's okay but how did i start
how do i keep going whoever you're
looking at look at their foundation
story how they started and chances are
you already have more than what they
started with
the trick to getting yourself into
action mode is to trigger yourself for
success triggering yourself for success
means you've taken the decision
making out of it that as soon as you
come up with an idea you have
trained yourself by default into action
mode
you see your brain will always talk you
down from things because it's trying to
keep you safe and it only understands a
world that currently exists that is
logical and practical
until you learn to trigger yourself for
success you will
constantly doubt your thoughts your
ideas and your actions
this video is going to help so today i
want to talk about this bag right here
a lot of you leave comments or newer
fans of the channel say why is doritos
sponsoring your videos evan why don't
you have a healthier sponsor
don't you know what bad doritos does to
your body
you should be promoting healthy living
doritos is not a sponsor guys this is
this is triggering me for success every
single day
and this isn't just some tiny bag it
looks small looking back here but
let me bring this up look at that this
is right next to my face look at how big
that bag of doritos is
i have a strategy and it's a weird
strategy so maybe you'll love it maybe
you won't but i have a strategy called
damn the doritos
i look at this bag so i'm sitting this
is how i'm working right i'm not sitting
i'm standing i'm standing on a
trampoline this is my
workspace right now right i'm standing
here i'm working
in the court of my eye i got steve jobs
up here and i got
i got this giant bag of doritos all i
want to do is eat this bag all day long
i want to destroy this bag of doritos
look at that giant chip
oh i'm going to start drooling soon
i love it i want to eat that all day
long
this bag is here as a reminder of how
great i am
this is the mental conversation inside
my head evan
you're awesome you're awesome for not
eating those doritos every day
and i want it as a reminder people say
it doesn't take a lot of willpower
no it it builds for me at least builds
the willpower
builds my strength every time i see that
bag of doritos makes me feel better
about myself
that i'm not eating it and i have the
strength to keep going
and so i have that here is when you're
on a diet right this is how it began
when you're on a diet
your friends your family the experts
will say get rid of all the junk food
from your house
get rid of it all because otherwise
you'll be tempted
and then you're gonna eat it and then
you're gonna ruin your diet i think that
is actually teaching yourself that you
suck
you're teaching yourself i'm a weird
duck you're teaching yourself that you
are not strong enough
to be around the thing and so i need to
get it out of my environment the only
way that i can stick to this thing
is if this other stuff is nowhere close
to me
i think you're telling yourself that you
suck i think it's a big crutch
and just like when you break your leg
you have a crutch your ultimate goal is
to not have a crutch is to walk it's to
run it's to be
stronger than before right and so as a
step one
maybe it's good right as a step one okay
fine you broke your leg you have a
crutch
you want to get on a diet you're
addicted to junk food get out of the
house awesome
but as soon as you go on vacation as
soon as you go to the office party as
soon as you go to new year's any kind of
party you're going to destroy the food
because you've trained yourself every
day that you suck that you're not
capable
i think you're a genius i think you're
stronger than you think
and so i tested it first with myself and
i thought you know what doritos are my
nemesis
right i love doritos oh my gosh she's
looking at that bag so i went to costco
and bought the giant-sized bag of
doritos and said i'm going to put this
on my desk
all day long because damn the doritos
because the doritos are stronger than me
i don't think so
right i'm evan carmichael and same thing
for you
that thing that is holding you that's
that's stronger than you
i don't think so remember who you are
remember how strong you are
and that's what this is here for and
it's been awesome to see people now take
this up
a friend of the channel uh leron was
trying to get off of sugar
and he has this uh coffee cup with a
saucer and he drinks his morning coffee
and he put two packets of sugar on the
saucer right next to the coffee so he
pours his coffee has the sugar right
next to it
and he just starts drinking it and puts
it down and looks at the
sugar packs and then just drinks the
coffee again and puts it down looks at
the sugar packs and his wife thinks he's
crazy
and he's a little crazy too you got to
be a little bit weird duck but but i
think this is actually how
you build your strength mark draker
another friend of the channel
is addicted to the peak freeings cookies
you know the ones that have the
the red on the inside and the cream in
the middle those are among my favorites
too
and so his ceo when he heard this went
out and bought
all these boxes of peak frames and put
it on mark's desk and he opened it up
and this is one of my favorite things to
do when whenever i'm around doritos or
something i really love to to eat
not just say oh put that away from me
don't be around me i can't have that
and not just look at it i want to smell
it
so mark took these cookies brought it
right up here peak queen cookies right
up here
oh and you can just see the joy on his
face
jess says he's bringing back memories
and just what those cookies are going to
taste like when they enter his stomach
and just
um goodness everywhere right the smile
on his face maybe a little bit of jewel
coming out he just
ah and then put the cookies down
and walk away and how great
that makes you feel as a human to say
here's one of my biggest weaknesses of
all time
bring it i own you put it down and walk
away
right i think that's how you actually
build strength by doing those difficult
things by triggering yourself for
success every time i see the doritos
back i feel better about myself i feel
stronger about myself and i want you to
do the same thing if any of you are
going to
take on that kind of challenge i want to
hear you i want to follow you i want to
i want to see how your journey is going
because it can be one of the biggest
most important life-changing decisions
that you embark on
the fastest way to accomplish anything
is to model someone who has already had
the same success that you are after
you can go around trying to figure out
everything by yourself trying to come up
with every new idea yourself
and you will slowly slowly make progress
towards your ideas
but until you recognize that success
leaves clues that whatever the thing is
that you're trying to accomplish
has already been solved by thousands and
thousands of thousands of people
that all you need to do is model their
success until you realize that
you're gonna constantly stay struggling
making slow progress
knowing that you're capable of more so i
first learned the power of violent
success with my first business
where i was struggling i was i was 19 20
not making any money 300 bucks a month
low confidence filled with self-doubt
not getting results
you know i turned down high paying jobs
to do this thing and own 30
of a company that seemed to be going
nowhere and i told my partner that i
quit and the thing that saved me
when i hit my lowest point was i am not
the first person to try to solve this
problem before
maybe my specific scenario yes biotech
software you know from toronto who's
done that before
nobody but a software company get into a
million dollars somebody's done that
before
how about i just look at their success
and try to emulate it
and so the only person i could think of
off the top of my head was bill gates
so i looked at bill gates and how he got
started and through partnerships and i
applied that lesson
to my business and in a short amount of
time had my first deal
for 13 and a half thousand dollars i
felt like a rich man you know i felt
like holy cow
to go from 300 bucks a month and saying
i quit to now having a deal in place for
13 and a half k
and more important the strategy that i
could use again and again again was
was life changing for me all because i
modeled success
and that was again when i was 19 20 so
now what have i done for the past 20
years is just model success what is my
youtube channel about what is this video
about
modern success why i have these people
behind me it's not for you it's for me
i want to model success they're
constantly pulling me up
to a greater spot whatever problem you
have has been solved
not exactly the specific minutiae
but by modeling bill gates it took me 80
percent of the way
you still have to figure out that final
20 percent but most people are trying to
figure out the whole
hundred that's the problem i was
struggling when i was trying to figure
out the whole hundred all by myself
i just come up coming up with new ideas
new ways new innovation but nothing
worked
[Music]
all you have to do is figure out that
last 20 percent and so look to your
heroes look to potential mentors whether
you know them
in person or not they've done it before
they can teach you success leaves clues
you don't have to go through this alone
and you can ramp up your success really
quickly nobody has the exact life you
want
nobody this is why so many people have a
challenge learning from mentors
because you're looking for one person to
teach you everything that one person
does not exist because you want a unique
life
because the perfect you doesn't exist
out there yet you have to create it
it's on you and so the way to get
through it is to model from different
people
it's to look at i want to learn this
from this person and this from that
person and this from this person this
from that person
and mix all those things together to
build an amazing life for yourself this
is partly why i created my channel
i want to be able to model success from
all sorts of different people and every
video that i make i've learned something
from
all the people that i've profiled i've
learned something from them i personally
me you haven't carmichael
haven't learned something from that
video then i don't post it
if you want to sign up for the entire
billionaire mindset series for free and
get the companion bonus pdf calendar
check the link
right there next to me i think you'll
love it continue to believe
and i'll see you there